[Music]
coleman is in uh billings montana hi
coleman welcome to the ramsey show
hey how's it going better than i deserve
what's up
so i have two statements and one
question so first off uh me and my wife
just got married two days ago
congratulations statement
thank you the second statement is that
we are both doctors and we
came together with 430 000
student debt so my question is
i know you guys state that we have that
it takes about 18 to 24 months to get
out of debt
um for us it's projected to be about six
years
we were just curious on some ideas on
how to say gazelle intense but as well
we'd like to enjoy life our pre-marriage
counselors
work with doctors and they really noted
that there needs to be times of
enjoyment and we just we're curious on
how we may do that
okay
well i i always use big numbers
in my math
and so
um
what is your income going to be
two dollars for the next
yeah for the next so she will be in
residency for three years oh so we will
have roughly 128 000 a year and then
after those three years it should jump
up to 2
30 250.
and
i thought you said you were a doctor
yeah i'm a doctor of physical therapy so
oh pt okay
yeah yeah so what are you making 80
i will be making about 70. yeah okay
starting out okay so you got 200 000
income for three years
uh 128 for three years
oh she's only gonna be she's gonna be
making 61. i'll be making oh i'm
misunderstood that was your household
inside yeah okay correct yep sorry
when you say enjoying life what does
that look like to y'all
so
me and my spouse's passion is traveling
hiking in the mountains and a lot of
family time and with her getting
accepted to a residency program a few
hours away from home
to see family it would cost
i mean a good chunk of change each time
why you get in the car and you drive
over there
it's a like a five-hour drive and then
hotels to stay in
well my thought is okay here's the thing
um
earl nightingale used to say
that the problem with achieving a goal
is not that what we have to do to get to
the goal it's what we have to give up to
get to the goal
so you you your your counselor
um
is an idiot
your pre-marriage counselor
um because here's the thing
you know you want to define enjoyment of
life as having 430 thousand dollars
crushing you from the top down
while you go running around acting like
you don't have debt and call that
enjoying life
i don't agree
i think that's really bad advice
and so i think there's a lot of things
you can do to enjoy life a lot of broke
people have really a lot of enjoyment in
their life
and dude you are seriously broke
i mean seriously bro
430
000 worth of screwed
you are so broke it's unbelievable how
broke you are and the sooner you guys
just own that
the better off you're gonna be
and quit walking around acting like it's
all okay it's not okay now are you gonna
clean that up in three years no you're
not gonna clean that up in three years
making 110.
you're not going to do that but y'all
have made a serious dad gum mess and we
want to travel
sorry
when you signed up for this doc thing
you you kind of cashed in the travel
card my husband and i used to do trip
tuesdays where we went on trips to
little national parks and you know we
were college age i was college age broke
and you know that cost what 20 30 bucks
in gas just to get there and
do something else that that and you know
if we want to call that enjoying life
have at it that's fine you want to call
dropping 20 grand on travel annually
because that's called enjoying life
because my counselor said to then your
counselor is an idiot